Puss in Boots did you lose your ball of
yarn you made the cat angry you're gonna
want to make the cat angry
puss and boots is yet another Shrek
related film and you know when I heard
that they were making a Puss in Boots
spin-off of the character in the Shrek
films I was like Shrek overload I mean
not only is there the four movies but
there's all these specials they do and
straight to DVD and you know it's just
like track however I always didn't
really like that character I really like
Antonio Banderas and fuck help this
sorry there was part of me that was
thinking who knows
this film is all about pussy boats it's
fully centered on him talked about a
relationship that he had with Humpty
Dumpty or in the past they were friends
and something bad happened I won't get
into and cause them to be enemies and
they decide to rekindle their friendship
and go after this mystical castle in the
sky and along the ride is Kitty voiced
by Salma Hayek and it's a big adventure
in the spaghetti western style believe
it or not this movie actually was pretty
good
[Music]
is it hard to hear please hit me I was
extremely surprised at how much fun I
have this movie because going in as I
said Shrek
overload I'm just I'm sick of Shrek at
this point I only like the first two
films and after that to me they were
just sort of like a cash grab this movie
is actually directed with a lot of
exuberance the director of this movie he
infused it with a lot of energy there
was a lot of really intense action
sequences believe it or not with the
cats also it was very funny
like I I laughed a fair amount of times
Antonio Banderas is extremely good as
Puss in Boots I loved his character it
was a great tribute to those old
swashbuckling characters like Zorro also
played by Antonio Banderas which is kind
of neat Poston blues legend tales of an
ancient treasure table for centuries and
guarded by giants in a castle in the sky
Salma Hayek was the voice of kitty she
was very good they're back together
again since the desperado films they
have another come together Zach
Galifianakis is the voice of Humpty
Dumpty now Humpty Dumpty's character got
on my nerves a little bit I felt like he
was in the movie just a little too much
I understand he's necessary to be in the
film
a lot because his character is important
but he just kind of wet nurse a little
bit in the middle section his character
was a little annoying at times that's a
minor gripe for the most part actually
this is an extremely fun action
adventure comedy show turns whole family
movie whether fine
measure will be given riches beyond
imagination shouldn't be golden eggs no
please say you have been shown enough
the CGI animation this movie is gorgeous
it looks so beautiful
each little whisker and fur finally
detailed and this is actually some of
the best 3d I have ever seen in one of
these CG animation movies it looked
really great a lot of stuff popped out
of you it wasn't just 3d to be 3d they
actually used it a lot and I love that
about this movie another thing I really
like about this movie is that they
embrace the corniness of it the
filmmakers seemed completely aware of
the silliness of a cat running around
fighting evil and there there's so much
humor that they got out of that
situation and they self parry themselves
a lot I really like the character Puss
in Boots I like the adventure he was on
I like the way this film was directed I
like to use like the music was really
good movie really surprised me it's
actually a lot of fun I'm gonna
recommend it I'm gonna give it a B+ my
thirst for a pinch of never be linked so
you may know the schmoes that have their
own little thing where they call the
comment section in their reviews
schmoeville well I decided that I should
name it something and a lot of people
voted on my Facebook officially I would
like you my stuck Ling's to comment on
this review down in stuckman Square and
let me know how you feel
corny I know but trust me I'll stick
just like this if you like this review
you can subscribe to my channel and get
stuck when eyes
[Music]